hasta ahorita hemos tenido varias rondas
de financiamiento para esta empresa de
venta de calcetines por internet nos ha
ido muy bien todas nuestras rondas han
sido hacia arriba una ronda hacia abajo
sería si bajar el precio de nuestra
acción y serían malas noticias para
nosotros y nuestros inversionistas pero
afortunadamente hemos tenido puras
rondas hacia arriba y pasamos de cinco
pesos por acción a 750 pesos por acción
y luego de ahí en nuestra serie b
pasamos a 10 pesos por acción eso estaba
muy padre del lado izquierdo de la hoja
de balance teníamos 30 millones de pesos
por una evaluación y 10 millones en
efectivo que nos dio el inversionista de
la serie b de este modo todo esto de acá
ahora vale 40 millones de pesos déjame
hacer una hoja de balance aquí abajo una
hoja de balance para reflejar esto de
aquí entonces voy a ponerlo más o menos
así algo de este estilo y aquí tenemos
11 millones
en efectivo en este momento todo esto de
acá vale 40 millones y del lado derecho
está el capital está aquí el capital
repartido en cuatro partes iguales para
los fundadores para el inversionista
ángel para el cuate de la serie a y el 4
de la serie ve muy bien hasta aquí están
las cosas pero imagínate que de repente
hacemos un estudio de mercado y nos
damos cuenta de algo fundamental nos
damos cuenta de que ahorita está pues
muy muy fuerte la competencia en la
venta de ropa internet así de ropa
interior por internet y de este modo
como los competidores están progresando
mucho ahorita el que logre conseguir la
mayor cantidad de clientes en un tiempo
muy rápido se va a convertir en el rey
de los calcetines digamos el amazon de
la ropa interior de esta forma es súper
importante ahorita poder crecer
rápidamente para poder pues ya sabes que
no se me entrar en más países para poder
contratar mejores diseñadores para tener
nuevas formas de envío y cosas por el
estilo
de esta forma ahorita tenemos que
conseguir mucho dinero digamos 200
millones de pesos y no lo podemos hacer
tan fácilmente a través de
financiamiento privado por esto vamos a
empezar a platicar
de una oferta pública primaria oferta
pública
pública pública primaria
primaria ok esto básicamente consiste en
que vamos a entrar en la bolsa mexicana
de valores y vamos a poder vender
nuestras acciones a cualquier persona
esto tiene varias ventajas o sea número
uno le da la oportunidad a estos
inversionistas de acá de realmente
alguien conseguir dinero porque hasta el
momento sólo tienen pues acciones que
ellos dicen que valen cierta cantidad
pero ya que se la puedan vender a más
personas entonces ya es dinero aquí en
efectivo dinero digamos un poco más
líquido
ok esa es una ventaja y la otra es esto
de que se puede conseguir mucho dinero
cuál es la mecánica hay te va esto se
realiza a través de un banco de
inversión banco de inversión inversión
ok entonces este banco de inversión se
va a encargar de hacer los trámites se
va a convertir en un líder de emisión
déjame lo pongo con con otro color se va
a convertir en un líder de emisión líder
de emisión de emisión y se va a encargar
de todos los trámites como es más o
menos la cosa pues este banco de
inversión va a ser el líder de emisión
pero se va a encargar de los trámites
con la con la bolsa mexicana de valores
va a hacer algunas proyecciones y
estimados iba a ser una cierta propuesta
para la bolsa mexicana de valores ya que
hace la propuesta este banco de
inversión va a contactar a otros bancos
para realizar un sindicato un sindicato
de más bancos de modo que sindicato de
modo que las acciones se puedan vender a
los clientes de todos esos bancos y que
se reparta el riesgo no me voy a poner
el riesgo repartido
de partido ok entonces más o menos eso
es el plan del banco de inversión le
dije al sindicato a todos los bancos de
por ahí que esta empresa la de
calcetines va a abrir acciones y con eso
pues ya se pueden vender a sus clientes
de cada uno de los bancos que usualmente
son clientes muy importantes con mucho
dinero que son clientes institucionales
ok vamos a la cuestión del precio como
le hace el banco de inversión para
determinar el precio que debe tener cada
una de estas acciones
bueno pues mira o sea tiene que tomar
varias cosas en cuenta no es no es como
hace una cuestión de que sea blanco o
negro porque hay varias cosas que se
tienen que tomar en cuenta más o menos
una cosa que es importante dejar me la
pongo por acá una cosa que es importante
es que el banco debe de poner un precio
suficientemente alto para que los
empresarios reciban el dinero que se
merecen pero por otro lado no puede ser
demasiado alto porque si no no se van a
vender las acciones o corremos el riesgo
de que la gráfica del precio se vea así
esto sería malo porque eso hace que se
desconfía de las ofertas públicas
primarias y eso no nos conviene entonces
nos conviene que la gráfica del precio
se vea más o menos así verdad déjame es
más vamos a vamos a ponerla por acá
abajo algo de este estilo
o sea conviene más que empiece a baja y
que luego crezca porque eso da confianza
en la empresa bueno entonces tomando en
cuenta estos factores y muchos otros el
banco finalmente ve esta empresa de aquí
ve cómo está con respecto a otras de la
misma industria y dice sabes que esta
empresa si se ve muy prometedora yo creo
que va a ser así una muy buena empresa
para confiar nuestro futuro de
calcetines así que vamos a darle una
evaluación de 80 millones de 80 millones
de pesos en total entonces estos son muy
buenas noticias para los fundadores y
para los inversionistas de las distintas
rondas hasta ahorita valían 40 millones
de pesos las 4 millones de acciones que
tenían pero ahorita fíjate eso quería
decir que valía 10 pesos verdad cada una
entonces
10 pesos pero ahorita tras esta
evaluación del banco como esto es de 80
millones van a pasar a ser 20 pesos por
acción
pesos por bueno precio por acción ok eso
está fantástico están muy felices estos
inversionistas y ahora el banco de
inversión le dice a la empresa mira ya
está tu valuación cuánto dinero
necesitas y entonces habíamos dicho que
necesitábamos esto de acá estos 200
millones de pesos para hacer los líderes
de los calcetines entonces le decimos
esto a la bolsa mexicana de valores a lo
mejor no pedimos más dinero porque si
perdiéramos 400 millones pedirían
perderíamos un poco del control de la
empresa porque habría demasiados
accionistas pero le decimos con 200
millones lo hacemos entonces el banco de
inversión y la bolsa mexicana de valores
se ponen de acuerdo nosotros como mesa
directiva decidimos emitir las acciones
correspondientes y se emiten y déjame
ponerle por acá que está el dinero de la
oferta pública primaria en realidad
debería ser un poco más grande verdad si
estos 40 millones esto debería de ser
cinco veces más grande que estudiar
pero bueno aquí son 200 millones de
pesos emitimos las acciones está según
se venden en la bolsa mexicana de
valores los bancos de inversión a través
del sindicato le dicen a sus clientes
que ya están disponibles las acciones y
que las comprende a montón entonces aquí
se empiezan a vender
y aquí ya hay muchísimas muchísimas
personas que empiezan a comprar estas
acciones y hay muchísimos muchísimos
accionistas que voy a poner así varias
líneas algo de este estilo y ahora la
empresa ya tiene su efectivo ahora
porque el banco de inversión está en
buena onda y porque decide ayudarnos con
todos estos trámites ya pues es muy muy
sencilla la respuesta el banco de
inversión recibe por esto una comisión
una comisión
y bueno depende mucho del país y de la
época pero usualmente está esta comisión
anda más o menos como por el 7% por el
7% del total de la oferta pública
primaria entonces en este caso como la
comisión es del 7% el banco de inversión
recibirían recibiría el 7 por ciento de
207 por dos es 14 o sea recibiría 14
millones 14 millones de pesos por su
trabajo que fue de un par de meses o
quizás tres meses y es un trabajo como
de 15 personas vale está súper bueno
este negocio verdad o sea es servir como
intermediario para la bolsa mexicana de
valores deja muchísimo dinero esto está
súper padre no cualquier banco puede ser
un banco de inversiones de citas y
cumplir algunos requisitos pero bueno si
se logra hacer es un muy buen negocio y
uno pues se entiende por qué surgieron
los bancos de inversión
hay un punto que te quiero aclarar antes
de terminar este vídeo creo que ya me
alargue un poco pero es un punto bien
importante porque finalmente ven o sea
ya ya platicamos de cómo se emiten las
acciones pero luego qué sucede con estas
acciones ya usualmente la gente piensa
lo siguiente usualmente este aquí estoy
digamos que aquí estoy yo voy a poner
carita feliz y usualmente yo voy a la
bolsa mexicana de valores entonces aquí
está la la bolsa mexicana de valores y
compro una acción entonces qué hago yo
para comprar una acción pues le digo a
la bolsa mexicana que me contacte con
alguien que tenga acciones y yo se lo
compro a esa persona entonces la bolsa
mexicana de valores está ahí como
intermediario de una segunda persona que
va a estar feliz a la cual yo le voy a
dar dinero le voy a dar dinero ya cambio
esa persona me va a dar una acción a
poner así y esta es una opción y
supongamos que la acción dice por ahí
calz
de calcetines va entonces él me da esta
acción pero esto de acá la gente muchas
veces lo piensa como que está
invirtiendo en la bolsa mexicana de
valores y de ahí se eleva a la empresa
cuando en realidad no es así en realidad
simplemente es como esto de acá es como
una reventa de esta acción que se
ofreció inicialmente en la oferta
pública primaria acá abajo acá abajo no
es así aquí se lo estoy comprando a otra
persona y este dinero no llega a la
empresa sino que este dinero llega a
esta persona de acá por otro lado sí sí
tenemos una oferta pública primaria le
voy a poner aquí o pp y entonces en este
caso yo como persona otra vez estoy por
aquí tengo carita feliz otra yo como
persona le voy a dar dinero
a alguien pero ahorita como si es una
oferta pública primaria ese dinero si se
lo voy a dar a la empresa a la empresa
que está emitiendo las acciones entonces
ahí está la empresa con
estas cosas aquí está el modo y tiene un
gran logo de calcetines bueno ok
entonces ese dinero se lo doy y a cambio
ahora si me da una acción y este es como
la la venta original de la acción por
así decirlo entonces aquí está
calcetines bueno
bueno obviamente verdad aquí si lo
compró en cierto precio digamos en 10
pesos pues se va a cierta cantidad de la
empresa digamos 7 pesos no un poco más
99 pesos con tres centavos pero de ahí
70 centavos son la comisión del banco de
este banco de acá que dijimos que es el
líder de emisión líder
de emisión
bueno espero no haber hecho este vídeo
demasiado largo pero si quería decir
esto que era muy importante que comprar
en la bolsa mexicana de valores acciones
a otra persona no es invertir en la
empresa pero comprarlo en una oferta
pública privada si lo es su dinero
realmente llega a una empresa y con esto
se hacen nuevas inversiones se le paga a
la gente se construyen edificios y este
dinero realmente si está entrando
directo a la empresa como efectivo bueno
es todo lo que te quería contar en este
vídeo espero que no haya sido muy largo
nos vemos hasta la próxima